Speaker 1: All right, I think you're really
going to like this clip or at least be horrified
by it in the sense that will be sort of enjoyable
but horrifying.
We've talked about the kind of like manufactured
nature of the culture wars that the right
is currently engaged in, and the manufactured
manufactured can mean a couple of different
things.
Manufactured can be manufactured by creating
irrational fear through lying to people and
making them think that something is a threat
to their way of life or to their family or
whatever, so it could be manufactured with
lies to create fear.
It can also be considered manufactured in
that it sort of like just based on either
misunderstandings or factual discrepancies
like about the 2020 election, the Big Lie.
It's unconstitutional and states violated
the rules and dead people voted.
And Mike Pillow has access to voting machines
that show you all these different things.
And it becomes sort of a cultural thing where
even though you might say, well, what's the
culture of claiming the election was lost?
It's this cultural fight where they see themselves
as engaged in a war where it doesn't matter
if they literally believe the explanations
as to how the election was stolen.
They see repeating that it was stolen as being
on the right team and fighting this holy war
of sorts, quite frankly.
One of the flashpoints so many of the flashpoints
in this include critical race theory, war
on Christmas, Communism and socialism coming
to America.
You could argue the Biden dementia thing is
part of the culture battle the Big Lie.
Certainly, there's a whole list of these things
and we can go on and talk about them.
Critical race theory is particularly interesting
because even more in an even more pronounced
way than with socialism and communism, the
people talking about it don't even know what
it means.
Oh, all the vaccine stuff also would be another
element of this.
A lot of the people saying critical race theory
is just a disaster.
They literally have no idea what it is.
They have no idea what it means.
They don't understand what it means in context,
out of context.
They just have no clue.
This is a video that has gone viral from the
good liars who do these really, really great
interviews.
The Good Liars interviewed a Virginia voter.
As many of you know, today is Election Day
in Virginia.
We're going to be covering the results live
of the gubernatorial race Terry McAuliffe
versus Glenn Youngkin, who's the Republican
candidate.
Very important race, and there are really
important issues at stake.
The Good Liars went and interviewed this guy,
Air Force veteran, at least according to the
hat the guy is wearing and said, What's the
most important issue?
And the guy said it's critical race theory.
And when asked what it is, the guy literally
has no idea what it is.
He just doesn't know what's going on.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: What's the most important issue
in the governor's race here in Virginia?
Getting back to the basics of teaching children,
not teaching them critical race theory now?
Speaker 1: Before even getting to the question,
what is critical race theory?
It's not very small government conservative
to want the governor to necessarily dictate
school curriculum.
I mean, remember these Republicans claim to
have this principle they abide by, which is
you only involve government in everything
when absolutely necessary.
If not, you leave things.
Leave it to school boards.
Leave it to municipalities.
Leave it.
You're right.
But here they want to elect Glenn Youngkin,
who has made a big deal out of we've got to
get critical race theory out and all these
different things completely in violation of
their so-called light touch conservative principles.
But then here comes the question What is critical
race theory
Speaker 2: and what is critical race theory?
Well, I'm not going to get into the specifics
of it because I don't understand it that much,
but it's something that I know what little
bit that I know I don't care for.
And what have you heard that you don't like?
I'm not going to, you know, I don't.
I don't I don't have that much knowledge on
it, but it's something that I'm not
Speaker 1: that I don't care for.
You know, this is like when a kid is presented
with, you know, broccolini for the first time
and the kid says, I don't like it, I'm not
trying it.
But what about it?
Don't you like it doesn't.
It doesn't taste good or you don't like tech?
I've never tried it.
I don't like it.
I don't want it.
OK, right?
But what?
I don't care for it.
The little I know about it, which is the fact
that you're trying to feed it to me.
Not good.
I don't like it.
It's a similar dynamic.
Will maybe inform yourself about what it is
first.
And our friend Anna Cass Berrien over at the
young Turks had a really good tweet about
sort of another aspect to that.
So how many layers are there to this?
There's a lot of layers.
There's people who are just goaded into culture,
war issues by fear and propaganda.
That's one aspect to the general incompetence
of the American public, which we will get
to in the voicemail.
Segment three is what Anna tweeted, which
is this is what manufactured culture wars
meant to distract you from elites robbing
this country.
Blind results in and folks like this guy,
they would probably if a Republican says corporations
are robbing you blind, they would probably
agree in some general sense to the extent
that they understand it.
If a Republican said, you know, even climate
change is an issue of patriotism, they would
go for it.
But very quickly, all of those substantive
issues, including issues on which there aren't
big differences between Republicans and Democrats
who are part of the same system that is not
working for tens of millions, if not more
of Americans.
They get distracted with something like critical
race theory, which this guy even admits that
he doesn't even know what it means.
So sad, funny, depressing.
Kafkaesque to go back to the earlier segment,
you tell me how you would describe it.